so do you think that people that grew up
that are comfortable are kind of at a
disadvantage then I do you do well but
we need them we need them because that's
that's our support and by the way many
of them are able to work through that
just like a lot of us that didn't have
everything as easy have to work through
our stuff but do I think there is a let
me rephrase in the way that I think you
asked the question do I think it's hard
to be hungry when you've always been fed
yes I think ambition is challenging in
that scenario but some take it the other
way I mean these first of all all these
conversations are incredibly General I
have a friend who I think about every
time I'm thinking about him right now
which is why I'm saying it out loud
every time I talk about it's challenging
if you come from a certain scenario to
be hungry his hunger came from his
awareness that everyone always would
think that he just started on Third and
a half base and so he and so he took
that as motivation and so like like
every human's different but I do do I
think
environment is a massive impact on a
human being yes I do and so if you grow
up in the east coast in in a certain era
uh in New York City New York tri-state
area you're going to be a certain type
of character versus somebody growing up
in a different environment and I do
think
adversity is the foundation of success I
do believe that but uh you know the Fear
Factor if you're willing to
put I apologize what do you think about
I agree no ABS
Absol no I agree with you but I also
think it could go the other way like
even for I I believe that I grew up very
comfortably I had a very different
lifestyle then how he grew up um I do
also think that I'm always trying to
prove myself and always trying to prove
that I'm not necessarily a neppo baby or
get everything because you give it to me
and because I work hard for this stuff
that I that I do and that I achieve and
so I want she was a very successful
teacher in the inner city for 10 years I
I actually have more empathy and
compassion for her than you because I
think about this every day I so get you
it's why I jumped in I apologized for
interrupting I think your point is so
profound and such an important
conversation and now that we are
starting to have terminology around it
to your point right bab that's right
well now on the podcast but I'm saying
like even when I went into college I
refused to put his name on the on the
applications or like when I went that's
why I couldn't get in to visit but like
I wanted to know that I was getting in
on my own Merit on my own hard work it's
the number one thing I I couldn't
understand that more the the the empathy
and compassion I have for children who
cuz remember how you and I got the luck
of the draw of certain DNA skill sets
right let just play it out and it's very
common for our children to potentially
get that as well the difference is to
your point I think it's harder I
actually believe this I think that it is
harder emotionally if you are someone
who's wired a certain way to have your
circumstance with a dad like that then
the reverse absolutely yeah because you
can never
win